[Music]
well good evening at welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight tomorrow the former
Special Counsel Robert Muller will spend
the entire day testifying before
Congress and that means that for yet
another 24 hours our leaders will fixate
on the virtually non-existent threat we
supposedly face from the government of
russia russia it's a show of course it's
a diversion but our news networks will
dutifully amplify it anyway they always
do turn on CNN or MSNBC tomorrow at a
point in the day you will hear
breathless coverage of an event that
contains precisely zero news why are
they doing this why are they so anxious
to make you care about something that's
entirely pointless that has no effect on
your life and never will
why maybe so it's she won't notice
what's actually happening in the rest of
the country things like this oh my god
they came over to talks about that that
video is real it was taken in the
Brownsville neighborhood of Brooklyn in
New York City it shows NYPD officers
being attacked while attempting to do
their jobs but remarkably it wasn't the
only time it happened yesterday a few
miles away in Harlem more officers were
attacked one was hit in the head with a
bucket watch this
what are those videos well what you're
really watching on the tape you just saw
is a society unraveling the men we have
hired to maintain order and keep us safe
were assaulted and humiliated they could
do nothing in response they couldn't act
because they know better than anyone
what kind of government they work for
it's a government that favors criminals
over Society itself
bill de blasio runs the government of
New York City watch him just a month ago
explaining how he's told his son that
New York City cops a racist murderers I
also want to say there's something that
sets me apart from all my colleagues
running in this race that is for the
last 21 years I've been raising a black
son in America and I have had to have
very very serious talks with my son
Dante about how to protect himself on
the streets of our city and all over
this country including how to deal with
the fact that he has to take special
caution because there been too many
tragedies between our young men and our
police - as we saw recently in Indiana
so it's easy to dismiss bill de blasio
as a buffoon because he is a buffoon but
if you're a new york city cop you can't
dismiss him the NYPD works for bill de
blasio
imagine hearing your own boss denounce
you as a bigot on the basis of zero
evidence no evidence whatsoever what
effects with that hat but it make you
want to risk your life to do your job or
to convince you just to give up you know
the answer you just saw the video when
cops give up like that criminals thrive
and that means that innocent people get
hurt something similar is happening in
cities across the country almost every
Democrat in the presidential race
suddenly sounds just like Bill de Blasio
I have challenged our Police Department
to recognize all of the ways in which
the uniform has been burdened by racism
we're going to crack down on police
brutality aimed primarily at people of
color training for police officers on
implicit racial bias and procedural
justice because to deny it exist
is to deny folks liberty and in many
cases life how can we continue to lose
the lives of unarmed black men in the
United States of America at the hands of
white police officers that is not
justice if you were young and black
you're treated differently because of
the color of your skin I don't believe
that it's just a case of a few bad
apples I believe that the system is
broken they all say it with total
confidence like they know it's true like
they've got the data to prove it but
they don't have the data because it's
not true it's an utter lie most cops are
not racist anyone who bothers to learn
anything about the subject knows that in
fact just this week a new study there
been others but a new study by
researchers at Michigan State and
University of Maryland found no systemic
racial bias at all in policing it turns
out that whether cops are black or
Hispanic or white or Asian or whatever
they have the same likelihood of using
force against a criminal suspect nor did
police show bias and who they use force
against turns out the shooting rate for
different races closely matches the
overall crime rate and the mass majority
of police shootings the criminal suspect
was armed or otherwise appeared to pose
a danger to police now obviously there
are bad cops out there of course just as
there are bad teachers out there and bad
senators and an awful lot of bad lawyers
but most cops are not biggest that's
just not true there's no evidence of it
maligning law enforcement though serves
these short-term political interests of
the Democratic Party so they do it but
the rest of us ought to be very worried
if you're over 40 you may remember that
this used to be a much more dangerous
country that it is today
huge parts of urban America were
uninhabitable because of crime you've
ever wondered why we built those
sprawling soulless suburbs everywhere
that's why we did because people were
afraid to live in cities and that could
easily happen again and it may people
like Pete Buddha judge take part Buddha
judges running around promising to cut
America's prison population in half
indiscriminately just the top 50%
rapists murders doesn't matter they're
out Cory Booker meanwhile is promising
to release the murderous drug lord
calling him a non-violent offender
every Democratic candidate of note now
supports de facto open borders of Mexico
sanctuary cities are everywhere in
America all of these are connected by a
thread they're all attacks on law and
order but there's a deeper problem what
they really are or attacks on society
itself and they're having an effect our
biggest cities are now filled with
filthy homeless encampments typhus and
bubonic plague have returned for example
to Los Angeles for the first time since
the conquistadors left Americans are
dying of drug Odie's in greater numbers
than were killed during Vietnam our
schools are a joke young people can't
get married buy homes or have kids big
tech increasingly controls what you do
what you see what you're allowed to
think these are some of the real
problems that we face in this country
problems that challenge our future as a
nation they're not small things and yet
our leaders ignore them completely to
them America has just two problems
Russia and anti-white racism and white
racism it's a delusional except it's not
really a delusion it's a diversion
they're lying to you on purpose and
hoping you won't notice